un día después de que la justicia turca
condenase a dos años y siete meses de
cárcel al alcalde Estambul el opositor e
krem y mamoglu las condenas por parte de
la oposición turca no se han hecho
esperar delante del ayuntamiento de la
gran ciudad turca la metrópolis turca la
coalición de partidos opositores se ha
reunido con una gran multitud de
personas para condenar lo que llaman un
juicio y una condena política contra el
candidato contra el alcalde de Estambul
uno de Los favoritos para ser candidato
para presentarse en contra de las
elecciones presidenciales de primavera
del año que viene contra resettaid
erdoan el presidente Turco de hecho
según muchos expertos en analistas está
condena viene para intentar evitar
precisamente que imamoulu el alcalde de
Estambul sea el que la candidata
opositor a estas elecciones y mamó los
uno de los candidatos más famosos y más
populares en todo el país después de que
ganase las elecciones locales en 2019
por primera vez ese año las ganó la
oposición en la última vez que se había
ocurrido fue en 1994 con el presidente
precisamente el presidente erdogan que
en ese momento fue alcalde según la gran
mayoría de los sondeos y mamólogo
ganaría estas elecciones en contra de
erdogan y lo ha hablado hoy mismo en
esta manifestación delante del
ayuntamiento de catalogado de que no va
a parar su lucha que va a continuar
tanto si es en frente del ayuntamiento
como en otros retos ha dicho el mismo y
que espera que en el futuro Turquía sea
un país mejor más libre y más
democrático de hecho uno de los grandes
puntos que tiene esta coalición de
partidos opositores que son muy diversos
entre sí es el intentar reforzar la
democracia turca dicen muy dañada por
los últimos años sobre todo del presente
Turco resev type erdoan y hacer
precisamente una coalición que sea en
contra de este presidente para intentar
acabar con sus 20 años de mandato